welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and after seeing
Multiverse of Madness and learning from
America Chavez that pizza Papa's pizza
balls exist in multiple universes but
not ours or Doctor Strange's it got me
wondering what brands celebrities and
media in reality also exist in the
Marvel universe so today I'm starting a
journey and breaking down what and who
from The Real World is canon in the MCU
from product placements to cameos to pop
culture references we're gonna take a
lens to the mundane parts of the MCU to
get a better idea of what the world is
like outside of the crime fighting in
super suits as you'd expect there's a
lot to break down so this video will
focus on the news and entertainment
Easter eggs in Phase One and my next
video will cover all the prominent
companies and products in phase one so
with that out of the way let's take a
look at what celebrities journalists art
and other bits of entertainment exist
within the MCU starting with news and
media because the very first scenes of
the MCU are absolutely full of magazines
in the first Iron Man a soldier in a
convoy asks Tony Stark if it's true that
he went 12 for 12 with last year's Maxim
cover models confirming that this
magazine company exists in the MCU due
to conflicting Canon and official
sources it's actually hotly debated
which year exactly the events of Iron
Man take place but whether Tony Stark is
talking about maximum cover models of
0708 or 09 it becomes pretty clear that
they aren't the same models as in our
universe he tells the soldiers that he
had a scheduling conflict with the March
model but that the December cover
featured twins so he's still hooked up
with an even dozen in reality Maximus
never featured twins on their cover so
right away we have some diverging
timeline variances or in addition to the
Jericho missile that dude's inventing
notches on his bed post shortly after
this we see that Tony was on the covers
of wired Popular Mechanics MIT
technology review Forbes and rolling
stone and we also see a solo cover of
Obadiah stain in Newsweek Tony mentions
that he got caught doing a piece for
Vanity Fair after spending the night
with MCU journalist Christine Everhart
and he greets Stan Lee mistakenly as
Hugh Hefner founder of Playboy magazine
on the red carpet in Iron Man 2. he also
mistakes Stanley for talk show host
Larry King as for newspapers the Boston
guardian and the Los Angeles Times pop
up while Tony is searching through Anton
venko's files in Iron Man 2. there's a
USA Today newspaper box in Thor and we
see both the Daily News and the UK
tabloid The Daily Mirror in Captain
America the First Avenger other IRL
journalists and news media Personalities
in Iron Man 1 and 2 include Mad Money
host Jim Cramer journalist orianna kit
CNN Anchor Christian Amanpour and Bill
O'Reilly from The O'Reilly Factor in
Captain America we see a poster for True
Crime with Aphrodite Jones on
Investigation Discovery from Time Warner
Cable in Times Square in The Avengers
MSNBC news anchor Thomas Robbins makes
an appearance as does former White House
Press Secretary Jay Carney ny1's Patrick
Kiernan does a vo at the end of The
Avengers we also see the ABC News
building in New York then for the
emerging New Media Market we get Tony
Stark watching a YouTube video of
himself and Iron Man 2. let's move on to
entertainment and nightlife so that if
any of us get trapped in 616 we can at
least plan A Familiar date night or
weekend getaway if you find yourself in
MCU Las Vegas for example Caesar's
Palace hotel and casino is ready to take
your reservation as evidenced by its
inclusion in Iron Man from Captain
America we learned that we have tons of
options to watch live performances back
in caps day we see the Orpheum Theater
which sits in the East Village at St
Mark's Place in the real world when cap
is unfrozen we see countless
advertisements for things to do in New
York when our guy gets to Times Square
Broadway Productions of Sister Act
Phantom of the Opera and Mamma Mia are
all advertised alongside a bunch of
adverts I'll be breaking down in depth
in my next video while on the subject of
theater though the Avengers has an ad
for the Alvin Ailey American dance
theater on the side of a bus as well as
a poster for Lion King the musical Up In
Harlem The Incredible Hulk fought
Abomination on the street outside of the
Apollo Theater Remington's Men of Steel
strip club and the Zanzibar Tavern
although the Apollo is in our real
world's Harlem neighborhood both
Remington's Men of Steel and Zanzibar
are not Remington's Men of Steel is
actually a now defunct Canadian strip
club and the Zanzibar Tavern is one of
Toronto's oldest adult nightclubs so how
do these places get to Harlem well the
real answer is that this scene was
filmed in Toronto but if we're taking
what we see as can in fact somehow in
the MCU these Ventures expanded their
butt shaking Services across the North
American Border when the Avengers team
up for the first time Tony really comes
in hot with the nicknames he calls Thor
Shakespeare in the park because of his
old-fashioned speech pattern as well as
Point Break because of his surferable
hairstyle and hot bad Hawkeye earns the
nickname Legolas from Tony obviously
because of his proficiency with a bow
and arrow this means that Shakespeare's
literary works one of Keanu Reeves
masterful pieces of 90s Cinema and the
Lord of the Rings series are all canon
in the MCU so is the cartoon series
Looney Tunes as Tony references Acme
explosives during a discussion about
Loki Nick Fury also mentions The Wizard
of Oz saying that like to know how Loki
used it to turn two of the sharpest men
I know into his personal flying monkeys
monkeys of course this reference led to
one of the greatest memes of all time
Steve rogers's I understood that
reference also in the Avengers Tony asks
Captain America of his secret to staying
fit is doing Pilates an exercise form
invented by German Fitness expert Joseph
Pilates in the early 20th century AKA
it's entirely possible that cap could
have done Pilates in training with his
army Bros because it was invented long
before he was frozen in time regarding
sports teams the only ones mentioned by
name in Phase One are the Philadelphia
Phillies and the Brooklyn Dodgers when
Steve wakes up from his cap nap a 1941
baseball game between the two teams is
broadcast in his room as for famous
artists an Iron Man Christine Everhart
calls Tony Stark The Da Vinci of our
time and pepper asks Tony if he wants to
buy another Jackson Pollock painting
next we all know that Tony Stark is the
absolute king of blasting heavy metal
and rock mostly due to the specific
songs played throughout phase one the
first non-diegetic sound we hear is when
pepper shuts off the music while Tony is
listening to institutionalized by
Suicidal Tendencies aboard his private
plane a few minutes later in the movie
Tony convinces Roadie to party with him
and starts blasting ghost-faced Killers
slept on Tony this particular member of
the Wu-Tang Clan actually goes by the
Alias Tony Stark and you can see his
music video playing in the background of
the scene in Iron Man 2. we hear a bunch
of bangers although Shoot to Thrill by
ACDC starts off as non-diegetic sound
when Tony makes his grand entrance at
Stark Expo it appears that the dancers
on stage are performing to this song
becoming a diegetic sound for all you
burgeoning film students diegetic sound
is music and audio that exists within
the context of a movie that the
characters can hear conversely
non-diegetic sound is audio that exists
just for the audience so for example
when Shoot to Thrill is played again in
The Avengers during their fight with
Loki in Germany this is diegetic because
Tony hijacks a quinjet's audio to play
it back to Iron Man 2's soundtrack while
Tony tests his vitals he plays the song
should I stay or should I go by The
Clash this represents his fear of dying
from the infection and caused by the Arc
Reactor in his chest he first chooses to
go by partying himself to death but
ultimately decides in the end to stay to
save the world and fix his devices at
Tony's birthday party you know the one
where he gets wasted and pees himself DJ
AM AKA Adam Goldstein is DJing sadly DJ
AM passed away before Iron Man 2 was
released and the film was dedicated in
his memory Tony asks him to play the
song Another One Bites the Dust by Queen
while he and Rhody kick each other's
asses lastly for Tony we see Iron Man
rocking a Black Sabbath bantee in The
Avengers my favorite diegetic sound
however is when the bar and Thor is
playing walk by the Foo Fighters not
only is this a
metaphor for the God of Thunder truly
relearning what it means to be a hero
for Asgard it also has pretty
interesting implications if the Foo
Fighters exist in the MCU it means that
Kurt Cobain also passed away in Earth
616. in fact walk is about Dave coming
to terms with Kurt's passing finally
let's talk about the books in off
authors that exist in both of our
respective realities Thor gives us a
whole Library cart full of them and we
even get to see one of those old school
read posters from 2002. although this
movie takes place in New Mexico the
poster features the fire department of
New York as for the actual literary
works we have summer Pony by Gene Doty
Patriots Gold by Virginia Francis Voigt
Trumpeter the story of a swan by Paul
Anixter mystery on Safari by Betty
Cabana Professor Diggins Dragons by
Felice Holman she said yes the unlikely
murder dumb of Cassie Bernal by Misty
Bernal the heat of the day by Elizabeth
Bowen the unanointed by Lawrence chin
score one for the sloths by Helen Lester
the king's trousers by Robert Krauss the
Royal nap by Charles Black just around
the corner by Margaret e martinoni the
long Christmas by Ruth Sawyer the junior
Classics Volume 7 the animal book David
the King by Gladys Schmidt the Walt
Disney parade Great Moments in fiction
the Walt Disney parade adventures in
fact the Walt Disney parade Fantasy on
Parade the secret history of giants by
Ari back myths and legends from around
the world a spot of bother by Mark
Hadden and Bonita Faye by Margaret
Mosley obviously the book titles that
stand out the most to me are the Walt
Disney ones Disney acquired Marvel back
in late 2009 and Thor was filmed in 2010
but even though this film was originally
produced and distributed by Paramount
this was the first post-acquisition
Disney reference in Phase One and yes
journalists Oriana kit does report live
from an event at the Walt Disney Concert
Hall in Iron Man 1 but that was filmed
before the acquisition and for those
wondering the first Disney Easter egg
produced solely on Disney's dime would
be the Lion King musical posters in The
Avengers these are just some of the
things from our world that I found to
also be canon in the mcu's phase one but
I want to know what I missed in the
comments like I said up top I'll be
doing a part two of this breakdown to
cover all the missable details that we
didn't discuss today so keep an eye out
for that vid coming soon follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you